[Music]
hi I'm Nazmul Idris I'm a developer
advocate on the Android team at Google
this is UX D for developers the show
where you can learn how to create better
user experiences today we're going to
talk about what UX actually means with
me I have a special guest Isabel Idris
who is a mobile interaction designer
that works for good technology thanks
for joining us Thanks
so Isabel I hear words UX design get
thrown around a lot and especially in
many different contexts people say if
you do this you will have a great
experience and your users will have a
bad time so what is UX well user
experience design is really an emergent
property of design that includes visual
design interaction design and
engineering so you can see in the slide
how all of these things really need to
come together and the whole must be
greater than the sum of its parts so if
any one of these things aren't great
they're going to let down the overall
user experience so user experience
really involves you focusing on all the
details as well as being able to really
zoom out and make sure that what you're
delivering has an overall really great
user experience that makes sense so you
mentioned that the words visual design
and interaction designer can you
describe the differences between the two
so I'm an interaction designer so I'll
start with interaction design it really
involves designing a sequence of screens
or sequence of steps that the user has
to go through in your application which
is what we call a flow in order for your
user to accomplish certain tasks so
those tasks depend on whatever it is
that your application actually does so
interaction design takes into account
how user interacts with the data and the
UI elements on each one of your screens
as well as how they interact with all of
the screens together so the data and the
UI really has to be strung together in a
way that makes sense for the user so if
you look at the slide this is an example
of a flow that an interaction designer
might show our might give to a developer
so the next slide here is an annotated
wireframe so this is something else that
I would also give to a developer
so the different annotations show with
each one of those UI elements mean so
right here we're showing the action bar
so we have the app icon a spinner some
icons and an overflow so a visual
designer what they do is they really
specify the color palette the
iconography that typography and all the
visual personality of your application
so they would surpass specify the exact
spacing for all the layouts of every
single screen so if you look at the
slide here this is what we would call a
red line so you can see it's a very
detailed layout of that particular
screen so visual designers would provide
the engineers all the graphics assets
and the icons and make sure that each
screen is just perfect so there's one
other example of a visual design these
are some things that a visual designer
would actually deliver to an engineer
these are like the different sizes for
your icons all the different font sizes
and all the difference the icon set for
your entire application so essentially
you're skinning the application you're
you're creating that that wonderful
experience I mean the visual aspect of
that experience that is going to
immediately be striking to someone yeah
that makes sense
so interaction design you can kind of
think of it that they would provide more
of a low res wireframe and then a visual
design would give you like a high-res
mock it was really subtle so I get it so
basically UX design has to take into
account interaction design visual design
and engineering and put them all
together in a way that delivers to light
at the end of the day right yeah so so
so from a developer's perspective the
way I'd like to think about it is that I
write code that might there's a visual
code I write a non visual code or I
write and both of those come together to
deliver the overall user experience but
the visual code specifically delivers
the UI is that a good way to think about
it as well yeah and I think that Google
now is a really great example of a
product that delivers a really great
user experience and it really embodies
awesomeness at every level the
interaction the visual and the
engineering right so I think it's
something that we can talk about a
little bit more do you have any examples
of how an application our experience
like Google now could hypothetically
have gone terribly definitely so we were
talking about visual design for quite a
bit so Google now is one of the most
striking
things about it is that the cards are
really really easy to easy to read the
typography is great it's very easy to
digest a lot of information without
thinking much at all so if Google now
delivered the same quality of
information it was accurate and relevant
but if it looked really bad like if the
margins were off and the padding was off
and the images are all ugly yeah then I
think you would make the user think that
it was a very unprofessional application
yeah I think that um things like
typography and spacing and that polish
that's in Google now is one of the
things that makes it so successful of
course the relevant data surfacing just
when you need it is crucially important
but what I really love about Google now
is how I can just glance at a card in
just a second I can get a lot of
information from it there's really no or
really low cognitive load to those cars
I can just glance at it and that's it no
that makes sense the visual design is
very important yeah so kind of switching
gears a little bit so let's say the
visuals for Google now since we are
talking hypothetically about how the UX
could could go horribly wrong so if
let's say Google now had just amazing
data was surfacing the content was
totally I'm sorry if the if the cards
looked really great as they do today but
let's say the data was lacking like it
didn't know your current location or
it's surfaced a card about some upcoming
flight that you have to be on and
details are wrong so in that situation
that would be a really bad user
experience right yes because um one
thing that I would feel at that point is
a user is that I can't trust the
information that I'm getting even though
it looks visually striking yet Trust is
a really important part of user
experience I'm glad you brought that up
because I'm Trust is like one of those
emergent properties that has to do with
really great design and really great
engineering so I think it's something
Trust is something that as developers we
should all really focus on because when
someone trusts your application that's
what's going to get your users to give
you these five-star reviews in the App
Store and these reviews are what's going
to make you ultimately successful that's
true in there your application as well
and a social proof in what you're doing
and so on so absolutely Trust is is one
of those very very important to merchant
the merchant properties that I think
that everybody should aspire to to
accomplish so let's use a different
example than Google now so I think we've
highlighted how bad visual design could
wreck experience how bad engineering
could
so sorry about how that interaction
design could also wreck it so we've all
used Android phones and if you think
back at the the first minute experience
you had with a new Android phone yeah
the first thing either it asks you to do
is sign into your Gmail account once
you've done that it basically
automatically signs you into all the
other google apps that you have like
play maps and youtube so imagine an
alternate universe where instead of this
wonderful flow we add a lot of friction
where let's say you've initially signed
it with Gmail but then for every other
Google application that you go to run
you not have to sign into it over and
over and over again like what would the
user think in that situation like I I
would be almost discouraged from using
my phone in the ways that I would want
to use it because of the tremendous
amount of friction that that had been
created in the interaction that I'm
having with with these different
applications so it's a it's a
higher-level flow if you will of how a
user interacts with with with with your
phone that's being impacted by
individual decisions that are being made
at the application level so that's one
of those aspects of you you know being
able to get the details right and then
actually zooming out and looking at how
all those details and in this case how
the first minute experience of using all
these applications really affects the
overall user experience which is the
Android user experience a croissant
exactly so it's almost as if like um you
have to be a good citizen as an
application developer your applications
have to be good citizen on the device
and not only deliver a good experience
inside of that application but also in
the context of the larger phone or
operating system that section exactly
that's actually living in that also
impacts things like battery life and yes
and so on okay so it's clear that many
things need to come together to make a
user experience truly great and and
clearly that design is everyone's
responsibility
exactly designers alone cannot create
great user experiences so I want to say
that one more time that designers alone
cannot create a great user experience
and not and are not responsible alone
for creating a user experience right it
takes an entire team so great user
experience really involves equal amounts
of amazing design an amazing engineering
effort and really amazing us across the
board by all the members of the product
team so just to give a shout out to all
these other people that are not
engineers or designers these
include tech writers product managers
project managers and directors managers
so you really need excellence at every
level definitely and also I think we
should we should also shout out to user
researchers for Tigers and so on who are
also part of the design team that
contribute in a big way to making sure
the experience actually works exactly
and works for users yeah and designers
can work to create and prototype really
amazing designs but in the end of the
day these designs still have to get
built by engineers so an example let's
say a designer creates a really amazing
and elegant and functional mobile
newsreader
application and they test it with users
it has really great feet user feedback
and they say okay this design is perfect
so they give it to the engineers but
when the engineers build it they don't
put in prefetching caching and they
don't do efficient data transfers and
they drain the battery tells us we
should always get a second data transfer
always do efficient data transfers so
these amazing designs are never going to
be fully realized or appreciated due to
these bad engineering practices and this
is something that designers have no
control over they can't control if you
use prefetching caching and if you do
data transfers inefficiently so overall
this is going to result in a bad user
experience you're usually going to feel
impatient and frustrated and overall
have at that time
definitely so UX design is really
important it's everyone's responsibility
and it's really important that every one
of the team comes together to make a
great experience also well thank you so
much for joining us today
this has been a great show do you want
to plug the luck scream oh yeah feel
free to join our Google+ design
community the link will be in the
description below and we're gonna put a
link to the episode on here and if you
have any questions or comments about our
episodes or just any questions about UX
in general or if you have suggestions
about topics you want us to cover for
upcoming shows please feel free to leave
us a post on there and we also curate a
tremendous amount of really good user
experience related information
especially for developers so please
check that out for that reason as well
thank you again and see you next time